[Music]
on this tuesday night rising
vaccinations and questions about
relaxing restrictions
what will fully immunize canadians be
allowed to do
if we don't provide people with this
guidance they're going to start to make
up their own rules plus a first nation
in the midst
of a covig crisis pleads for help
turmoil within the green party the
challenge to anime paul's leadership
the mess in the senior ranks of canada's
military
what's the defense minister going to do
about it
global national with donna friesen
[Music]
good evening and thanks for joining us
we begin tonight with a milestone for
canada on covid19 vaccinations
and case counts the caseload is now the
lowest it has been since the end of
summer 2020.
there are fewer than 15 000 active cases
right now and
just over 800 new cases were reported in
the past 24 hours in canada
it is a massive drop from just over two
months ago
when 9 200 daily new cases were being
reported
and canada has hit a new mark on
vaccinations
according to our world in data canada
now leads the world
having the largest share of the
population 65
with at least one vaccine dose that's
ahead of israel and the uk
we're still far behind though on second
doses that sits at just 13
but it is climbing as more vaccine doses
arrive in the country
we are on track for a two dose summer as
eric sorenson explains the federal
government is now under pressure to give
canadians clear guidance
about what we can do when we're fully
vaccinated
it's another wave not a pandemic wave
but a public health wave
ontarians who've had one vaccine dose
are lining up in astonishing numbers for
their second dose at this pop-up clinic
it's important for me to get the second
vaccine i want to
be able to see my family i want to
protect my family
life is beginning to return to normal an
update on international travel and
border restrictions is expected within
days
we hope and believe these measures can
evolve
in a phased appropriate way over the
next number of weeks but as canadians
become
fully vaccinated what else will change
critics say the government is not
providing clear guidelines
if i'm vaccinated fully can i be with
other people who are fully vaccinated
the answer to that is yes
i think this kind of guidance is
extremely important to give people an
idea of what's safe
and what can be done in israel those who
are fully vaccinated get a special pass
so they can attend concerts
in the u.s the center for disease
control has issued guidelines for the
fully vaccinated
to dispense with masks and distancing in
this country for now
public health officials suggest
canadians assess their own risk
though new guidelines are being looked
at we are discussing this with the
provinces
and i think that um you know we will be
providing that kind of tool
if you like if we don't provide people
with this guidance they're going to
start to make up their own rules
in calgary for example the annual
stampede is considering a vaccine pass
for events with large crowds
when it comes to certain venues we are
exploring
the idea of proof of vaccination or
rapid
testing canada has become a world leader
in administering first doses of vaccine
and guidelines for what comes next
should keep pace with that
says this doctor we need to recognize
that effectiveness by
creating guidance to show people that
when you get vaccinated
your life will change and that's an
incentive canada may need
some incentive as the rate of first
doses begins to slow
[Music]
down in france they've come up with this
a promotion promising the vaccinated
freedom from pandemic restrictions
eric sorensen global news toronto
[Music]
canada has relied completely on other
countries to produce and supply us with
vaccines
many of them come from a pfizer plant in
belgium prime minister justin trudeau
got a tour of that plant today and
abigail beeman was there too abigail
donna the majority of doses in canadian
arms come from pfizer and 11.6 million
of them were made
here at this belgian plant pfizer has
been
just so solid as a partner the prime
minister has described pfizer as the
reliable workhorse of canada's vaccine
heard tuesday he had a chance to see how
they're made and thank the people who
make them it's a very canadian thing to
say thank you so i absolutely love it
plants like this push out supply as fast
as possible but the need is overwhelming
the world health organization pegs it at
11 billion doses there's a debate raging
about whether to waive the drug maker's
intellectual property patents
to make vaccines in more places faster
the u.s now supports the move
some countries with big pharmaceutical
presences like germany and the uk
do not ip rights are the reward
for innovation and breakthrough research
and vip rights themselves do not
tell the whole story of how to produce
successfully a vaccine europe has put
forward an alternative plan that
includes compulsory licensing which
would get around the waiver but
compensate the drug maker
just on thursday last week i think the
debate moved
a little bit further with most members
agreeing to engage in tax-free
negotiations
the prime minister has been asked many
times but still won't take a side
this is a complex situation it's not
just a finding a single
silver bullet we're a minority
government
we're heading into an election
opposition parties may
grab hold of this and say geez this is
going to be bad for
investment and the government i think is
just
not wanting to engage and take a
stance that i think most canadians would
support and would like them to take
the prime minister wraps up his overseas
trip before most people can travel
easily again the question of vaccine
passports still needs to be resolved
here in europe there's a plan in place
canada doesn't yet have one donna
all right abigail beeman in belgium
tonight thanks there are places in this
country still struggling to cope with
cases of covid19
the kashichuan first nation in ontario
is one of them
it is in crisis tonight there are 216
active cases of kovid 19 there
in a community of just eighteen hundred
people keshuan is near james bay almost
one thousand kilometers north of toronto
it's remote there are no roads in or out
so helping those who are ill
is difficult fourteen people have been
airlifted to hospital
michael couture has been speaking to the
chief in kishiwan
well i never seen so scary
points in my life since i became a chief
leo friday has been chief of kichawan
first nation for the last six
years his community experiences yearly
flooding
and struggles with chronic housing
shortages
but this covid19 outbreak has shaken him
this is the first time that i
encounter some kind of a dangerous
feeling
for my people more than 200 members of
his community have coveted 19.
a number of them had to be airlifted out
of the community for medical help
it's unclear how the virus got into the
remote region
but cramped living conditions fueled the
spread
we have 15 to 20 people living in
overcrowded homes
already people have compromised health
and lung problems from black mold
and now covid is moving through children
and babies many of those children were
too young to be vaccinated
the federal government has sent a team
of 15 canadian rangers to assess the
situation
and is ready to move more resources to
the region this is a minute to minute
discussion with with all with with
public safety but prepared to ramp up
as well as the community needs it and as
they navigate sort of this critical
14-day period isolation tents and
temporary housing structures will be
going up soon
but there's an urgent need for food and
other supplies
some groups like the mennonite central
committee have stepped up
and chartered private supply planes the
6500 pounds of food
that was more than ten thousand dollars
in in and that was reasonable the chief
of kosciun first nation
says the immediate help is welcomed but
he wants a long-term solution to the
housing crisis
so something like this doesn't happen
again
donna all right mike lookatura reporting
from ottawa tonight thanks
the ontario government is committing 10
million over three years to identify
and commemorate burial sites at
indigenous residential schools across
that province
the first step will be gathering
information from survivors and then
forensic investigations of at least 12
separate residential school sites
indigenous leaders have praised the
provincial government's commitment but
said the catholic church also needs to
acknowledge its role
i believe that the catholic church
needs to come forward and make efforts
to bring the pope
to canada for a formal apology
to all first nations across canada
for us it's genocide that's what took
place
they wanted to wipe us out
ontario's announcement is the first
major provincial commitment following
the discovery of what are believed to be
the unmarked graves of 215 people
on the site of a former residential
school in kamloops bc
some members of the green party of
canada are trying to remove
anime paul as leader the party's federal
council has scheduled a vote for tonight
that if successful could
kickstart the removal process less than
a week ago mp jennica atwin abandoned
the green party and crossed the floor to
join the liberals
she said months of internal strife over
the party's stance on the conflict in
the middle east was a distraction
enemy paul was elected leader in october
and is reportedly rejecting calls to
resign saying she is
not going anywhere
there's some breaking news in the middle
east israel has launched airstrikes on
gaza ending the ceasefire reached
26 days ago the israeli defense force
claims the strikes are retaliation for
what they call
incendiary balloons launched from gaza
which set fires on israeli land
earlier today hundreds of israeli ultra
nationalists some chanting death to
arabs paraded through east jerusalem
israel's newly appointed prime minister
naphtali bennett permitted the march and
it infuriated palestinians
israel claims today's strikes on gaza
hit hamas targets and says it is
prepared for a resumption
of hostilities cascading consequences
the crisis in canada's military
coming up the pressure on the defense
minister to fix it
the questions keep mounting about the
leadership of the canadian armed forces
the military has now lost its two top
commanders
all of it a cascading effect after
global news first broke the story of
alleged sexual misconduct in the
military
it's hard to keep track of who has been
shuffled out
lieutenant general mike rouleau who was
second in command
is the latest to step aside he went
golfing with general jonathan vance who
is under investigation for sexual
misconduct
at least eight other men in the senior
ranks are being investigated too
or have stepped aside or been removed
including major general danny forte who
the prime minister had put in charge of
vaccine logistics
mercedes stevenson our ottawa bureau
chief is with me mercedes
start with forte he is not happy about
being yanked from the job and he's
pushing back
what's he alleging donna danny 410 has
launched a court challenge to the
government's decision
to remove him from his job as the head
of canada's vaccine rollout
in documents filed with the federal
court fortan makes some incendiary
allegations against the prime minister
the minister of health and the minister
of national defense
saying the decision to get rid of him
was politically motivated
and overrode the military chain of
command without him having the ability
to defend himself
before having his reputation destroyed
the court documents reveal a
behind-the-scenes look at what fortes
says happened
in the days leading up to his removal
including an allegation that the head of
the public health agency of canada
warned fortan to prepare himself for the
moment that they determine
you need to be let go and to keep your
bags packed
forte says comments like that one where
he was told
and another where he was told that the
political calculus had changed
proved the whole thing was politically
motivated and amounted to what he calls
inappropriate political interference by
prime minister justin trudeau and
members of his cabinet
who forte says got rid of him for their
own personal
and political gain overriding the chief
of the defense staff
and leaving out key context about the
allegation he was facing
prime minister justin trudeau when asked
about it today would only say it's
before the courts
so mercedes where does all of this leave
the government and the military how do
you move forward when you keep
losing top people well that's a great
question and a tough one senior military
leaders
don't appear to respect the defense
minister they're not listening to him
and they certainly don't seem to get it
based on that infamous golf game
this is now becoming an issue for the
government of civilian control over the
military
but the government seeming to have lost
control on this file
it's increasingly becoming an issue and
it blew up today
in question period listen to this the
canadian armed forces is literally
falling apart before our eyes when will
the prime minister
fire his incompetent minister
we know that we have a lot more work to
do to making sure that we create an
inclusive environment in the canadian
armed forces
and we will get it done and then there's
the question of
where minister sajin is he hasn't come
out other than question period to give
interviews or public statements
and this is all very complicated for the
military too donna they continue to lose
key leaders in an institution that is
supposed to be protecting
the country and our national security
it's hard to do
that when you're putting out daily fires
though dealing with ongoing bad
decisions and not just historic
allegations
donna all right mercedes stevenson in
ottawa thank you
wolf warrior diplomacy still ahead
china's approach to critics at home
and abroad
you're watching global national
[Music]
u.s president joe biden touched down in
switzerland today ahead of his summit
meeting with russian president vladimir
putin in geneva
it will be there first face to face
since biden took office and
biden brings nearly half a century of
foreign policy experience with him
he has said he thinks putin is a killer
he's also called him a worthy adversary
and says
he's not looking for conflict the last
four u.s presidents have sought to
re-engage with russia with
limited success as the case of the two
michaels detained in china drags on the
chinese government is being
looked at with some trepidation that
anxiety is rooted in beijing's growing
assertiveness and its
enigmatic leader xi jinping when she
first took office back in 2012
the west hoped for a new era of reform
and opening
instead as jeff semple reports the
opposite has taken hold
when xi jinping was elected chinese
president in 2012
western observers were filled with hope
he promised to liberate china's way of
thinking
and many believed he would become a
great reformer
not a wolf warrior
she's combative foreign policy style is
nicknamed
wolf warrior diplomacy after the hit
chinese movie
wolf warrior 2 a brutal blockbuster
about a chinese soldier
battling evil american mercenaries xi
jinping
has been particularly successful and
skillful
in playing the political game in
aiming at his political opponents
president xi
is cracking down on dissent both at home
and
abroad arresting the two michaels and
temporarily blocking
billions of dollars in canadian exports
prime minister trudeau has tried to walk
a fine line talking tough
at times but also unwilling to take any
real action against china
we've made it very clear to ourselves
that the soft approach does
not work but for a lesson in what can
happen when a mid-sized country
challenges
china one need only look down under
china's trade sanctions have hit
industry after industry
australia has become a political
punching bag
beijing banning a long list of aussie
exports
after australia's prime minister called
for an inquiry into the origin of kovid
19.
people have learnt from the australian
experience that it's unwise to go
as a single nation and and criticize
china
because you'll be picked off so western
allies are now
locking arms this month's g7
and nato summits took aim at beijing
calling china a systemic
security risk as partners we must stand
strong and united but already cracks are
showing
germany and other european nations are
downplaying the rhetoric
the chinese market is crucial to german
automakers
beijing meanwhile is fast building its
own alliances
with russia among others and accused
nato of slander
facing growing opposition from the west
china's
wolf warrior president is showing his
teeth
jeff semple global news toronto that's
global national for this tuesday i'm
donna friesen
tonight's here canada is humber river in
toronto we'd love to see your canada
please email it to viewers at
globalnational.com
thanks for watching hope to see you here
again tomorrow take care of yourselves
bye-bye